for Generations the people of the island
of mindoro in the central Philippines
have lived off the waters around them
but the tanker carrying 800 000 liters
of unrefined fuel sanked off their Coast
last week causing an oil spill that has
devastated their livelihoods
swimming has been banned because of
health concerns and that's hitting
businesses that cater to tourists
the effects are massive because there
are no visitors arriving for a vacation
or to unwind nobody is renting our
Cottages because of the swimming
restrictions and there's no one checking
in it stinks and the sand is full of oil
we're saddened because all the tourists
have booked us for the summer season and
the upcoming Holy Week have already
canceled this March we have already had
cancellations after hearing the news of
the oil spill the effects of the oil
spill are huge
not only on jobs and businesses but on
marine life as well several towns in the
province of Oriental mindoro have
declared a state of calamity
as well as one in neighboring antique
which is more than 100 kilometers away
from where the tanker sank scientists
say as much as 36 000 hectares of coral
reefs and mangroves are at risk of
damage
it will take a long time it might take
years because the Marine biodiversity
will be damaged the Marine protected
areas where the fish lay eggs if those
are destroyed will lose the fish
reserves in our ocean it's possible that
the fish will leave the area and not
spawn there again and the fishermen will
not have any catch
authorities are now racing to contain
the league with booms around the area
where the vessel has been located
a submersible machine is on its way to
siphon off oil that's left in the cargo
but cleaning it all up may take months
or even years
Barn below Al Jazeera Manila